i want to start with a thank you uh i
really appreciate what you do and
entertaining me and just want to say
thanks
that is the nicest thing man thanks a
lot we see each other a lot and i really
do appreciate that and i've been waiting
for that thank you
finally
what people don't realize though is you
slipped me a five dollar bill to
actually say that on camera i did at the
last premiere right and i just want to
throw that out there that i i don't do
that for you know for free um so
uh if someone has actually never seen
anything that you've done before what is
the first thing you want them watching
and why
wow
it's a tricky question um but i
well i would say
in this order
forgetting sarah marshall
followed by muppets
and then the end of the tour
only because those happened
chronologically and they sort of
highlight uh
a shift i made that i'm very proud of
i'm really proud of forgetting sarah
marshall because it was uh
i mean i was 25 26 years old when i
wrote that and
took some guts i ended it with a puppet
musical
uh and then my dream was to make the
muppets and then i did the scariest
thing which is i took a project that i
didn't think i was good enough for um
and so that was something i feel proud
of and i took with me like
scare scare yourself you hear that a lot
and and it i always thought it was a
cliche oh i you know try to
scare myself
but i really understand it now this is
your life
you know what i mean you're in the
middle of your life and you're supposed
to be challenging yourself and growing i
didn't quite get it until my early 30s
um also all three of those projects are
what we call real good
ah thanks yeah thanks just throwing that
out there um so with this movie
specifically first of all congrats on it
i watched it last night
really really enjoyed it was it as
simple as charlie just texting you being
like what are you doing for the next few
weeks
i mean i know you i know you helped come
up with the idea but you know what i
mean i do i do it it was that simple it
was four of us uh
me charlie justin and andy are all
buddies and so we talk and text
frequently and it was the heart of kovid
and
basically we're all stir free
and i uh
i didn't know what to do charlie didn't
know what to do none of us did and so on
one of our chats we were like yo we've
got a location we've got writers we've
got a director we've got actors we're
supposed to be making something that's
what you're supposed to do
during times when you don't know what to
do if you're creative and that's how it
started
what's crazy about it though and i read
it i don't know how much it's true that
you went to the location and then didn't
leave until the film was done is that
true
yes
that it's
that's it's so that's so unusual for
people to realize movie making yes uh
that's right well it was that period of
covid when people were like wiping down
their bags and stuff you know what i
mean we didn't know
we didn't know how long it was gonna
last we didn't know
you know anything and so
there was a real question of safety
you know at the time
and so it was like get to one place
everyone get tested and then
create the bubble you know
sure uh it's funny judge just made the
bubble um anyway so
you know but i looked at the credits and
like it's the shortest credits i've ever
seen in the movie for like for people
that are like you know three
stars making something so i'm just
curious if it was like you carrying
lights on set and one of these things
where everyone was doing everything
we had a really dedicated and amazing
crew of i'm guessing uh 40 you know
something like that 40 people and
we
rented a motel
and they all stayed there and so i don't
know what was happening at the motel i
was living on set but i bet that was fun
and then um and then everyone it really
did feel like film camp
that was like that was the vibe around
the whole experience um i love that the
fact that the clip in the movie that you
guys do is three amigos
a because it's an amazing movie b the
scene is really funny but there's a
subtext to that scene that's very
reflective to what these three
characters are going through and you
know who they are um was that one of the
reasons why the clip is in the movie
absolutely
yeah it um
it's it's weird uh that clip that clip
sort of defines the theme of the entire
the entire movie
two people struggling for water and one
person with a full canteen
a hundred percent um one of the things
about the movie and what i i love when
movies don't give you everything that
allows the audience to use their
imagination saying that with with your
character there's really no backstory
which i love but did you ever decide
this is the actual backstory these are
the reasons he's doing this did you like
come up with those kind of things
um
a little bit but i was more kind of
locked into this thematic idea that
nobody represented the part of us that
knows something is fundamentally wrong
and cannot put their finger on it which
i guess is the definition of
powerlessness is like
this sense that this is not right and
there is nothing
i can do to change it um that was sort
of the energy that i tried to bring into
kind of the whole thing
um
and it's a guy asserting the little bit
of power that he has it's like
i can't do anything else so i'll do this
last question for you uh i'm obviously
looking forward to you doing shrinking
um
and i'm just what can you tease people
about it where are you in the
development or filming yeah we start
shooting in three weeks uh
i don't think they've announced it yet
but we got a crazy cast um
and it it's it's bill lawrence and brett
goldstein you know who created it and so
man i feel really lucky i'm doing that
uh i'm on winning time and i'll go back
for season two of that i haven't arrived
on the show yet but i'm coming
um
i'm just and i have this i'm just
feeling really really
effing lucky uh and five dollars i'm
five dollars richer so we're good yeah
exactly
i got i gotta wrap i'm just gonna say
man congrats on this i wish you nothing
but the best hey you too i really
appreciate this cool thanks later man
see ya
you